hi I'm Andrea Crawford with IBM cloud so
we're going to talk about dev sec ops
dev sec ops is all about DevOps with the
lens on security the benefits of dev sec
ops primarily address observability this
is observability in context of how
observable is your application delivery
process in and of itself do we know
what's happening between user story all
the way through to code bill deploying
manage and continuous improvement
another benefit is traceability so are
we able to understand what user stories
are being deployed and managed in the
runtime environment and can we prove it
the next benefit is confidence and this
is all about the business having a
trustful relationship with the IT
organization that what is being
delivered is actually what started off
in the beginning of the pipeline as a
requirement or a user story and the last
benefit here is compliance this becomes
increasingly important for specific
industries like healthcare public
federal banking and the like we need to
have compliance built into this release
pipeline and it needs to be engineered
from day one dev sack ops can really
involve a lot of different activities in
the supply chain or this pipeline part
of those are things like well-formed
user stories over here these user
stories have to be the appropriate sized
well-formed and be understandable by the
development team additional security
features are going to be piped in over
here in the code phase
these involve things like test-driven
development
pair programming these are specific
activities and new ways of working that
mitigate the risk of someone or somebody
introducing a bug or a defect at the
coding level we also are able to achieve
better test code coverage by writing our
test cases first and then writing our
code we also have security aspects that
we can infuse into the build phase here
and this is more along the lines of
linting and making sure that our code is
able to conform to standard coding
practices we also have this notion of
scanning particularly for things like
infinite loops or undeclared variables
these are all potential vulnerabilities
that could manifest themselves in very
adverse ways once we get into production
and then some additional security
practices around the deploy aspect can
also be infused so with the advent of
cloud native and images there are even
things like notary services where we can
ensure that images are not only
immutable but docker images that are
being deployed are in fact the same in
images that are produced from the build
process and then we have in the manage
section here activities such as mutation
detection and this is all about making
sure that any runtime containers that
are in your operational environment
don't all of a sudden spark some sort of
vulnerability in the runtime environment
that you may not have caught in the
build phase so dev sack ops is all about
infusing risk mitigating activities
throughout this pipeline here so what
are some of the use cases for infusing
secure
well pretty much everything but in
particular if you have issues with a
lack of visibility in terms of how how
your applications are progressing
through the pipeline and who's deploying
what when and in which environment if
you have cases where you are troubled
with audits and being able to prove with
empirical data that what you are
delivering is in fact what you started
out with in the beginning of the
pipeline empirically tracing back all
the way through from beginning to end if
you have issues with unified governance
and being able to use this pipeline here
across your enterprise in a uniform way
so making sure that we are delivering
software by appropriate by appropriating
the right kind of risk mitigation are we
doing the right kind of activities
throughout this pipeline to mitigate the
risk of getting our digital reputation
in trouble at an enterprise level so
these are the use cases for employing
some of these dev sec ops principles
there are industry standard
organizations like Oh wasp or open web
application security project that
actually have Software Assurance
maturity models to address not just
these pipeline activities but also
governance construction and even
recommending secure coding practices
that you would find over here so to sum
all of this up
Duff's a cop's is all about a holistic
secured by design approach to code to
delivery and it all involves people
process and tools thanks for watching
this video
if you have any questions or comments be
sure to drop a line below if you want to
see more videos like this in the future
be sure to LIKE and subscribe